[Música]
[Aplausos]
alguna vez sintieron esa incomodidad en
el cuerpo sintieron que no pertenecían
sintieron la presión de tener que
encajar a
bueno yo sentía eso gran parte de mi
vida fui la pobre en un colegio privado
y la rica en uno público la machona
entre las chicas muy finitas entre los
pibes hetero curiosa para las lesbianas
y la torta para los heteros la horda de
las flacas y la flaca de las gordas muy
vaga para hacer negro y la anr de la
balanza siempre sentía que hay una serie
de requisitos para hacer algo y la
verdad que no calificaba bien en ningún
espacio
eso me construyó como una persona
bastante insegura
me costaba tomar la palabra 'tenemos
ocupar el espacio así transite mi vida
hasta que entré a la facultad de
ciencias económicas me quería
universidad pública pública y gratuita
porque si no no hubiese entrado
en la facultad aprendí muchas de las
herramientas que uso hoy en día pero más
importante que eso es que me cruzo con
personas que me abrieron la cabeza
entendí que el conocimiento no se
construye repitiendo lo que me decían
siendo una buena alumna a un buen logro
sino que como estudiante tenía que
cuestionarlo todo y para eso tenía que
exponerme en cada crítica me topé con
docentes compañeras colegas y amigas que
me ayudaron a ver el mundo de otra
manera donde creer que todos y todas
teníamos las mismas oportunidades era de
mínimas fantasías el derrumbe de la
meritocracia un antes y un después
gracias a estas personas y el camino es
crítica constante que inauguraron es que
encontré una explicación a esta
incomodidad que me haya acompañado tanto
tiempo y que ahora quiero compartir con
todos y todos ustedes
vivimos en una sociedad generada que
quiero decir con esto que todo lo
clasificamos como femenino o masculino
según sus atribuciones lo que
clasificamos como femenino tiene que ver
con lo emocional lo sensible y lo
subjetivo
mientras que lo que clasificamos como
masculino tiene su opuesto es racional
literal y objetivo no es casualidad que
todas las características femeninas sean
mejores o sirvan más para el hogar donde
es mejor ser detallista cuidadosa y
concreta las características masculinas
son mejores o sirven más para el
desarrollo de las ideas el ejercicio de
la política en la economía
a lo largo de la historia los varones
fueron los encargados de construir el
conocimiento y las mujeres las reinas
del hogar los mundos no se mezclan
osasuna osos la otra porque porque los
estereotipos de género nos marcan el
camino a seguir si no hacemos con
vaginas se nos impone un camino rosa y
si nacemos con pene una celeste
imagínenselo profunda que es la
dicotomía que si nacemos con genitales
ambiguos algo que pasa para el 2% de la
población mundial
estamos hablando de la misma cantidad de
pelirrojos y pelirrojas en el planeta
en esos casos son los padres con
recomendación del personal médico los
que decidirán que caminen pondrán sobre
la vida de la persona que acaba de nacer
muchas veces con intervenciones
quirúrgicas no vaya a hacer que se cree
una persona que no entra en ninguna
categoría
en el mundo de construimos lo que
deseamos lo que realmente queremos
pareciera no importar lo que importa es
encajar encajar y obedecer no hay
opciones por fuera del varón mujer y es
que el reconocimiento social se da a
partir de tu expresión de género si la
sociedad le digo como mujer entonces se
espera cierto comportamiento de voz y si
te lee como varón entonces espera a otro
cuando no son fácil de leer o no te
comportas como se te demanda entonces
ahí empiezan los problemas en el mejor
de los casos hablamos de miradas
recelosas comentarios aleccionadores en
el peor de los casos hablamos de que si
sos lesbiana
muchos varones creas que te pueden
corregir violando ten
son los riesgos de no encajar de no
obedecer
todo el tiempo naturalizamos las
imposiciones de género y hablamos de
instinto maternal como si fuese algo tan
real como la menstruación y la
menstruación no hablamos todavía se
escuchan hablar de los relojes
biológicos que nos van a decir cuándo
vamos a hacer madres porque lo vamos a
hacer eso no está puesto en duda la duda
es cuando entonces cada uno y cada una
sigue y debe seguir el camino que se les
fue impuesto y el resultado está a la
vista las mujeres nos dedicamos a cuidar
y los varones a gobernar las mujeres nos
encargamos de la reproducción y los
varones de la producción se nos negó el
conocimiento porque no teníamos nada que
aportar a nuestro mandato no estén
inteligentes es ser lindas
los varones que si son inteligentes
desarrollaron el conocimiento que
comprendemos hoy en día o cuántas
autoras mujeres leyeron ustedes en sus
carreras
solo hay una sola en todo el plan de
estudios john robinson que me la
presentaron como la mujer del profesor
robinson
entonces tenemos un conocimiento sesgado
producido por y para varones
esto tiene implicancias muy reales y
concretas en la vida de todos y todas y
yo como economista las vegas' las
cuentas nacionales de todos los países y
tiene que ver justamente con el rol de
la mujer en este sistema nuestro rol
reproductivo como es natural nos
dedicamos a la crianza de nuestros hijos
e hijas al cuidado de las personas
enfermas ancianas hacer las compras
cocinar planchar limpiar y el sinfín de
tareas no reconocidas ni pagas pero me
sumé en tiempo y esfuerzo las mujeres
realizamos el 76 por ciento del trabajo
doméstico no remunerado
ya lo tenemos en común todos todas y
todos es la duración del día y esas 24
horas las mujeres dedicamos más de 6 a
estas tareas no pagas
en el caso de los varones en el 58% de
los casos entre en el famoso
es un amor no sabes cómo ayuda en la
casa
para el otro 42% no podemos decir ni
siquiera decir incluso en esta encuesta
del uso del tiempo del indec se muestra
como una mujer que trabaja a full time
dedica más tiempo al trabajo doméstico
no remunerado que un varón desempleado
eso está mal dado son malos los varones
no no estamos hablando de maldad no
necesariamente son malos estamos
hablando de educación de imposición de
lo que esperamos de cada persona que
cambia según su género donde el
privilegio de uno depende del trabajo de
otras
esta jornada de trabajo anotada
repercute en nuestra disponibilidad de
tiempo para conseguir un trabajo
remunerado para estudiar o incluso para
disfrutar del tiempo libre hacemos un
uso más intensivo del tiempo que
nuestros padres varones
cuando analizamos el mercado de trabajo
vemos que las mujeres participamos menos
eso es porque el rol de ama de casa está
clasificado como una actividad típica si
inactiva
la mujer que dedica todo el día al
trabajo del hogar para el indec es
inactiva y para gran parte de la
sociedad también o nunca escucharon o
dijeron no no no trabaja es ama de casa
las que sí participan en el mercado de
trabajo pago lo hacen en condiciones más
hostiles que sus pares varones tenemos
mayores niveles de desempleo y peores
trabajos
es decir que las que si entran tienen
más chances de no conseguir trabajo o de
conseguir uno sin aportes ni obra social
ni ningún tipo de seguridad además de
eso vamos a ganar menos vamos a sufrir
de la famosa brecha salarial que en
nuestro país es del 27 por ciento
es decir que tenemos que trabajar 15
meses y 9 días para ganar lo mismo que
nuestro par varón ganó en un año es
decir que trabajamos tres meses y nueve
días gratis
por eso inauguramos el 9 de abril como
el día del pago igualitario para
visibilizar justamente esta desigualdad
y ahora que si nos ven y ahora que les
pusimos datos a esta desigualdad de
género y desarrollamos que es
estructural y tiene que ver con cómo
constituimos al mundo y nuestro lugar
dentro de él tiene que ver con la
construcción del conocimiento con el
aprendizaje en las escuelas en las casas
en las calles en los barrios y en las
instituciones y eso es justamente lo que
va a decir la economía feminista el
universal planteado jamás nos representó
al conjunto represento a los varones
seis blancos heterosexuales y
propietarios universal hizo a los más
privilegiados en visibilizar a todo el
resto y lo que venimos a hacer como
movimiento feminista es justamente a
desmontar todo esto a de construir un
mundo del que nunca fuimos parte
igualitariamente el que siempre
parecíamos estar en falta
pero la transformación no sea
individualmente la lucha es colectiva
todas pensamos que el problema lo
tenemos nosotras o el resto porque
atomizados los problemas para no
hacernos cargo de que lo que hay que
cambiar es mucho más profundo
entonces entendí en esta construcción
que está bien sentirse incómoda no
pertenecer ni encajar porque a cada una
a cada una se nos es en un lugar muy
preciso en esta sociedad y no vamos a
decir que no encajamos y no queremos
encajar vinimos a ocupar los espacios
que nos fueron negados pero los vamos a
ocupar haciendo los propios
reconstruyendo los para reconstruir los
sin imposiciones
yo encontré mi lugar en la militancia
feminista donde no tenía que cumplir una
serie de requisitos sino que lo que
buscábamos entre todas era visibilizar
esta sociedad estructuralmente desigual
y en este camino es que abrimos cada vez
más puertas y aristas de esta
desigualdad que es de género es de clase
de raza de etnia y de orientación sexual
pero una vez que visibilizamos esta
desigualdad que sabemos que está mal
porque no es natural entonces tenemos la
responsabilidad histórica de aportar a
su erradicación la responsabilidad
política de transformar esta sociedad
que nos incomoda tanto
entonces las lees y los invitó a sumarse
a esta ola para como decía rosa
luxemburgo hace más de un siglo
construyamos entre todos un mundo donde
seamos socialmente iguales humanamente
diferentes y completamente libres muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
i